Und ...
... being recorded.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiß Petra Frankel.
Könnten Sie bitte die Nachname bestäbieren?
F-R-A-N-K-E
Genau.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 42 Jahre.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin 1,73.
Und wie schwer sind Sie?
80 Kilo wiege ich zurzeit.
Entschuldigen Sie, könnten Sie wieder ...?
80 Kilo.
Und Frau Frankel, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was führt Sie zu uns?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe solche Bauchschmerzen.
Das fing gestern ...
Ja, gestern Nachmittag fing das eigentlich an.
Also so kurz nach dem Mittagessen.
Wir hatten so einen schönen Kartoffelsalat mit viel Mayonnaise und gebratenen Fisch.
Oh, und dann hatte ich mit einmal solche Bauchschmerzen.
Und ... also ...
Das strahlt bis in den Rücken rein.
Und mir ist schlecht.
Und ... also ...
Jetzt kann ich überhaupt nichts mehr essen.
Heute Nacht habe ich auch ganz schlecht geschlafen.
Und ich habe so geschwitzt.
Und ... also mir geht es richtig ...
Aber die Schmerzen sind richtig heftig, ja.
Und ...
Haben die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam begonnen?
Das hat ziemlich plötzlich angefangen.
Plötzlich nach dem Essen hat das begonnen.
Und ... sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen sie auch wieder weg?
Nee, die gehen überhaupt nicht weg.
Dauerhaft.
Und ... wo genau sind die Schmerzen lokalisiert?
Und ... Sie haben gesagt, dass die Schmerzen ...
Könnten Sie bitte noch mal wiederholen. Wo genau sind die Schmerzen lokalisiert?
Na ja, so oben im Bauch.
Vielleicht ... ich würde sagen oberhalb vom Bauchnabel.
Und ... also nicht unten im Bauch, so wie ...
... wie Periodenschmerzen oder so.
Sondern irgendwie weiter oben.
Und ... ja, mir ist halt auch so schlecht.
Und irgendwie ... das strahlt so rund herum.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass überall rund herum richtig alles wehtut.
Und ... können Sie bitte die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind die Schmerzen ...
Es drückt ganz stark.
... oder ist es ...
Drückende Schmerzen haben Sie.
Und ... war Ihnen übel?
Mir ist immer noch übel.
Ja, immer noch übel.
Und ... müssen Sie sich erinnern?
Ich muss ... zum Glück nicht.
Aber ich mag jetzt heute den ganzen Tag gar nichts essen.
Und ... ja, wie gesagt, ich fühle mich wirklich ... ich fühle mich schlechter.
Und ... haben Sie Duffel bemerkt?
Nee, das nicht. Aber ich muss ... also ich habe ganz dolle Blehungen.
Haben Sie etwas ausprobiert, um die Schmerzen zu linden?
Ja, ich habe ein Ibuprofen genommen.
Und ja, da hatte ich das Gefühl, dass es ein klein bisschen besser geworden ist.
Aber dann ist es wieder gekommen.
Haben Sie die Enhebeschwerden früher gehabt?
Oder ist das das erste Mal?
Ja, ich habe das kürzlich schon mal gehabt, schon ein paar Tage.
Da ist es aber von alleine wieder weggegangen.
Das war auch nach dem Essen und nach dem Essen.
Aber so schlimm wie jetzt war das nicht.
Aber Sie haben vor drei Tagen noch einen Enhebeschwerden?
Vor vier Tagen.
Und ... gibt es bestimmte Auslöse für Ihre Schmerzen?
Ja, ich habe ja gesagt, nach dem Essen.
Nach dem Essen.
Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10?
Wobei 1 leichte und 10 unerträgliche Schmerzen sind.
Also das ist schon sehr heftig.
Ich würde sagen 8. So etwas würde ich sagen.
8, mhm.
Und sind die Schmerzen mittelsalz oder schlimmer geworden?
Sie haben so gesagt.
Also für die Hand.
Und Sie haben aber nicht erbrochen?
Nein.
Nein. Mhm. Ja.
Haben Sie Fieber bemerkt?
Das nicht. Ich habe mich aber nicht gemeldet, aber heute Nacht habe ich furchtbar geschwitzt.
Geschwitzt. Mhm.
Und ... gibt es andere Beschwerden, die Sie hinzufügen möchten, Frau Franke?
Mir reicht das völlig.
Die wahnsinnigen Bauchschmerzen.
Ja.
Bauchschmerzen. Mhm.
Und ich möchte noch eine weitere Frage stellen.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit in letzter Zeit?
In letzter Zeit habe ich eigentlich ganz gut gegessen, aber jetzt diese Tage ... ach nee.
Gar nichts.
Mhm.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Abworter zugenommen?
Ich habe mich jetzt nicht gewogen in letzter Zeit.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie nicht gut geschlafen haben gestern.
Ich hatte solche Bauchschmerzen. Ich konnte nicht schlafen.
Wegen Bauchschmerzen.
Und ... haben Sie Schüttelfrost oder Nachtschwitz bemerkt?
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich heute Nachtschwitz habe.
Geschwitz. Und ... haben Probleme beim Stuckhalt oder beim Wasserlassen?
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich ...
... dass ich Sublärung habe.
Mhm. Na, bitte.
Und ... gibt es in Ihrer Krankengeschichte wichtige Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, also ... ich habe ein bisschen ...
Und ... ja, auch die Blutfettwerte sind wohl ein bisschen hoch.
Und ... ja, womit ich mich schon viele Jahre rumquäle.
Ich habe Migräne.
Und dann geht es mir auch ziemlich schlecht.
Mhm. Haben Sie leidene Bluthochdruck und Blutfettwerte?
Ich habe halt so Cholesterin erhöht.
Seit wann? Aber haben Sie?
Also noch nicht lange. Vielleicht so 3-4 Jahre.
Vorher hat man das gar nicht festgestellt.
Sie haben 30 Jahre gesagt, oder?
3-4 Jahre.
Seit 4 Jahren. Bluthochdruck und Hyperlipidema.
Und seit Langem leiden Sie unter Migränen.
Ja, das fing in der Pubertät an.
Mhm. Und wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, als Kind habe ich die Mandeln rausbekommen.
Und nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, aber ich kann Ihnen jetzt nicht sagen, wie die heißen.
Also gegen die Migräne nehme ich natürlich was.
Und dann habe ich auch für den Blutdruck Tabletten.
Aber ich kann Ihnen jetzt nicht sagen, wie die heißen.
Die liegen zu Hause auf dem Tisch.
Aber Sie sind jetzt nicht dabei?
Nein, weil ich solche Schmerzen hatte, bin ich einfach schnell losgelaufen.
Und ich möchte Ihnen eine weitere, routinemäßige Frage stellen.
Rauchen Sie oder haben Sie geraucht?
Ja, ich rauche schon ein Päckchen am Tag, würde ich sagen.
Könnten Sie wiederholen? Entschuldigen Sie?
Eine Schachtel Zigaretten am Tag rauche ich wohl, ja.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke abends gerne so zwei Flaschen Bier.
Und wenn es mal was zu feiern gibt, wird es natürlich auch mal mehr.
Und dann trinken wir auch mal einen Schnaps oder einen Kurs.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen oder haben Sie früher Kontakt zu Drogen gehabt?
Nein, ich habe auch mal probiert.
Reagieren Sie allergisch auf bestimmte Medikamente oder Lebensmittel auf?
Ich habe so ein bisschen Heuchnupfen.
Heuchnupfen. Seit wann?
Ja, so seit 10 Jahren ungefähr ist es aufgetreten.
Ja, und sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Meine Eltern leben noch, ja.
Und sind Sie gesund?
Ja, die haben das, was alle haben.
Ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck und Blutfettwerte.
Die nehmen alle Tabletten.
Ihre Mutter oder Ihr Vater?
Beide.
Beide. Hochdruck und Blutfettwerte.
Ja.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Einen Bruder habe ich.
Einen Bruder? Ist er noch gesund?
Nein, der hat eine Leberprobleme.
Der hat richtig viel getrunken.
Und der hat ganz große Leberprobleme und hat auch so Wasser im Bauch.
Und so, also dem gibt es schlecht.
Der ist acht Jahre älter als ich.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet, klar.
Und was machen Sie für das Leben?
Ich arbeite in einem Labor, in so einem Farbenlabor von so einer Farbenfabrik.
Da machen wir so Qualitätskontrollen und so.
Arbeiten Sie im Labor?
Und haben Sie Haustiere?
Nein, das haben wir nicht.
Ja, meine Frage habe ich gestellt.
Wenn Sie etwas hinzufügen möchten, kann ich nochmal hier notieren.
Ich habe Ihnen ja gesagt, was für Schmerzen ich habe.
Und sonst könnte ich eigentlich nichts dazu sagen.
Sie haben mich ja auch schon viel gefragt.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was ich Ihnen noch erzählen kann.
Ich möchte nochmal das fragen.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familiengeschichte wichtige Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Sie haben gesagt, dass Mutter und ihr Vater unter Bluthochdruck und Blutverzweite leiden.
Ja, das haben wir alle.
Aber sonst wüsste ich nicht, dass da noch irgendjemand etwas hat.
Ich meinte etwas.
Und ich möchte noch das fragen.
Haben Sie regelmäßige Perioden?
Ja, das funktioniert ziemlich gut.
Vielleicht gibt es eine Möglichkeit für Schwangerhaft?
Nein, das ist ausgeschlossen.
Ich weiß, wie sich das anfühlt, wenn man schwanger ist.
Ich habe zwei Kinder.
Das ist gänzlich anders.
Sie haben zwei Kinder und beide sind gesund.
Ja, zum Glück.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Horschnupfen haben.
Gibt es noch bekannte Allergien bei Ihnen?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Das Einzige, was mir mal aufgefallen ist,
ist, dass ich im Frühling, wenn die Haselnüsse blühen,
dann habe ich auch bei den Birken ordentlich Schnupfen.
Ich habe auch mal getrennende Augen und rote Augen.
Das geht dann aber wieder weg, wenn die große Zeit der Pollen vorbei ist.
Das war alles von mir.
Vielleicht habe ich einige Fragen zu stellen vergessen, aber ich weiß nicht.
Wie geht es denn jetzt weiter? Was kann man gegen die Bauchschmerzen tun?
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben nicht gefragt, wo die Schmerzen aussteigen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass es aus der Rückseite steigt.
Rundherum tut es überall weh.
Aber was kann man dagegen tun?
Woran liegt es denn, dass ich diese Bauchschmerzen habe?
Für die Bauchschmerzen haben Sie Ibuprofen eingenommen.
Ja, aber ich kann auch nicht immer Ibuprofen nehmen.
Was ist denn der Grund für die Schmerzen?
Sie haben gefragt.
Wir müssen, um eine richtige Diagnose zu stellen,
erstmal einige Untersuchungen durchführen.
Danach können wir alles klar erzählen.
Wir brauchen einige Laborwerte.
Weil es notwendig ist, können wir Ultraschall durchführen.
Natürlich muss die körperliche Untersuchung jetzt anfangen.
Das machen wir jetzt gleich.
Danach muss ich meine Chef über ihre Situation besprechen.
Und kann ich Ihnen eine Therapie einleiten.
Okay. Gut.
Möchte jemand Fragen stellen?
Ich bin total genervt von dem Echo.
Manchmal ist es, manchmal nicht.
Aber möchte jemand Fragen stellen?
Wollen Sie schon ins Ars Ars Gespräch einsteigen?
Wir können langsam sein.
Guten Tag, Frau Chef.
Ich möchte Ihnen heute unsere gemeinsamen Patienten zeigen.
Frau Petra Franke, 42 Jahre alt, 173 cm und 80 kg.
Sie stellte sich seit gestern Nachmittag
bestehende Bauchschmerzen mit Asstralung in den Rücken
und im oberen Bereich vor.
Die Patienten berichten, dass die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten sind.
Plötzlich und nachdem Essen aufgetreten ist,
sind die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten.
Nachdem Patienten
die Schmerzen nach dem Essen vom Kartoffelsalat aufgetreten sind,
die Schmerzen sind dauerhaft.
Die begleitenden Symptome sind Schwitzen und Übergheit.
Die Patienten klagten über noch drückende Schmerzen
und die Schmerzen nach Eingabe vom Ibuprofen sind besser geworden.
Sie hatte vor vier Tagen noch eine ähnliche Beschwerden.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 8 von 10 bewertet.
Nach der Frage über Fieber und Nachschweiß
sowie Appetitlosigkeit wurden verneint.
Begleitend hat sie gelungen.
In der kranken Geschichte bestehen arterielle Hypertonie
sowie Hypolypidemie seit vier Jahren.
Sie leidet seit einem Jahr an Migränen.
Die Anfalloperationen sind bei ihr als Kindheit
Handgelenkoperation bekannt.
Sie reagiert allergisch auf Haselnussblumen
sowie Birke, die sich mit Konjunktivität reagiert.
Sie leidet unter Hochschnupfen.
Sie leidet mit Medikamenten
wegen arterieller Brutalität und Hypolypidemie ein.
Die Medikamentenistin ist nicht dabei.
Sie raucht einen Schachtel Zigaretten am Tag
und trinkt zwei Flaschen Bier.
Sie konsumiert keine Drogen.
In der familialen Geschichte bestehen
bei der Mutter und dem Vater
Blutdruck und arterieller Hypertonie und Hypolypidemie.
Sie leidet an Zirrhose,
weil sie viel trinken hat.
Sie hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
Sie hat keine Haustiere. Sie ist verheiratet.
Sie leidet unter Hochschulblumen.
Sie leidet mit einer Pancreatitis und
eine Kolitis.
Und was machen Sie diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Mit Diagnostik? Können Sie das bitte wiederholen?
Was machen Sie diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Ja, erstmal haben wir körperliche Untersuchungen durchgeführt und wir kontrollieren bei der
Palpation, ob sie Druckschmerz hat und über Epigastrium besonders.
Und wir können nochmal noch auch bei der Palpation Murphy Zeichen kontrollieren,
was auf eine Apandecitis herbeiziehen.
Und bei der Palpation Inspektion und Perkussion können wir überprüfen.
Und danach können wir im Labor ein kleines Blutbild kreieren,
so wie Elektrolyte, Leberwerte besonders wichtig und Pancreas Enzyme,
so wie CRP-Werts, Amlasung, Lipas müssen wir kontrollieren.
Und Abdümmen, Sonos können wir durchführen, das ist Goldstandard.
Genau.
Und können wir mit der Verdacht auf Urkosventrökülle eine Endoskopie durchführen.
Würde man machen.
Und natürlich Urias Schnelltest.
Urias auf HP.
Ja, für Helikopter Pylori können wir überprüfen.
Und RACP und vielleicht...
Wenn nicht da der Verdacht auf der Palpation geht.
Und wenn wir mit Verdacht auf Choleraethiasis können wir noch RACP durchführen.
Okay, gut.
Ja, dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden, was mit Ihrer Patientin ist.
Wir gucken Sie uns nachher noch zusammen an,
wenn Sie alle Ihre Laborwerte und Ihre Untersuchungsergebnisse beieinander haben.
Ja?
Gut.
Okay.
Ich versuche jetzt ganz vorsichtig mit ein bisschen Abstand zu sprechen, schön leise.
Dann geht es, glaube ich, ohne Echo.
Nicht ganz.
Können Sie mich verstehen?
Ja, gut.
Ja, was mir aufgefallen ist, Sie machen extrem oft E.
Das ist signifikant mehr als normal.
Wir machen es alle, klar, aber Sie machen es ungefähr nach jedem zweiten Wort.
Und das ist anstrengend zuzuhören.
Und ich gebe ihr zu, dass wir jetzt heute unter diesen technisch etwas schwierigen
Bedingungen sicherlich eingeschränkte Möglichkeiten hatten.
Aber das ist wirklich, versuchen Sie da ein bisschen dran zu arbeiten.
Und Sie hatten auch nicht so einen ganz stringenten Plan, nach dem Sie vorgegangen sind.
Sondern Sie hatten, ja, Sie haben manchmal Sachen, die die Patientin schon gesagt hat
und wo Sie auch schon gefragt hatten, erneut gefragt.
Zum Beispiel die Verdauungsbeschwerden haben Sie noch mal nachgefragt, obwohl Sie das
vorher gesagt haben.
Und auch mit dem Fieber, da haben Sie, das haben Sie auch noch ein zweites Mal nachgefragt.
Da hatte Sie schon gesagt, dass Sie in der Nacht geschwitzt hat.
Also das wäre schon gut.
Das wäre schon gut.
Das, was der Patient Ihnen sagt, registrieren und nicht noch ein zweites Mal nachfragen.
Es ging auch ein bisschen durcheinander.
Gut, also wir versuchen mal weiter.
Ja, also wir waren ein bisschen durcheinander bei den Fragen.
Es kamen viele Sachen dann unmotiviert nochmal an der anderen Stelle wieder.
Und Sie waren auch in den Fragen Formulierung nicht so ganz sicher.
Sie haben also nicht so fest formulierte Fragen gehabt.
Und schwächer war das dann noch im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Die Formulierung, da sind Sie auch nicht sehr stringent vorgegangen, sondern haben so ein
bisschen die Informationen hier und da eingestreut.
Ich weiß nicht, wie Sie sie notiert haben oder so.
Aber Sie haben nicht so ein schönes durchgehendes Bild gezeichnet.
Die Patientin hat eigentlich ja ziemlich konkret ihre Beschwerden geschildert.
Sie hat gesagt, sie hat Bauchschmerzen und zwar im Oberbauch, die strahlen in den Rücken
rein und sie hat mehrfach gesagt, die Schmerzen gehen rund herum.
Da müsste eigentlich schon mal so ein Lämpchen aufleuchten.
Und die Schmerzen sind sehr stark.
Sie sind postbrandial aufgetreten.
Auch der Begriff wäre, Fachbegriff wäre natürlich ganz gut.
Und die wurden leicht gelindert durch Einnahme von Ibuprofen.
Aber es gab eben diese Nebenerscheinungen oder Begleitsymptome wie Übelkeit und
Meteorismus und Inappetenz, Schlafstörungen in der Nive wegen der Schmerzen.
Und sie hat nachts geschwitzt und da haben sie gesagt, hat sie alles verneint.
Hat sie aber nicht.
Sie hat gesagt, sie hat geschwitzt in der Nacht.
Und ja, das war diese Geschichte.
Die Familienanalyse war richtig.
Also Vater und Mutter beide mit Hochdruck und Hypercholesterinämie.
Bruder mit der Leberzerose.
Und bei der Patientin selber, die Vorerkrankung haben sie auch richtig geschildert.
Die Voroperation, sie hat gesagt, sie hat die Mandeln rausbekommen.
Also Tonsilektomie, nicht Handgelenk.
Also ein Hörfehler, der bestimmt jetzt den technischen Problemen geschuldet ist.
Und genau die Medikamente, da wusste sie den Namen nicht.
Das ist richtig.
Und so, was mir ein bisschen gefehlt hat, war im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch,
dass sie erwähnt hätten, die gürtelförmigen Schmerzen.
Und da sind wir auch schon fast bei der Diagnose.
Sie haben das als Differentialdiagnose angegeben.
Es ist eine Pancreatitis und kein Ulcosventrikulis.
Sie hat die Schmerzen, sehr starken Schmerzen,
und hat die eben angegeben im Oberwauf und gürtelförmig.
Das ist, also nach der Schilderung wird es hier als Pancreatitis eingestuft.
Aber sie haben das ja als Differentialdiagnose auf alle Fälle mit erwähnt.
Und sonst wüsste ich eigentlich nicht, was wir noch zu der Geschichte sagen könnten.
Als Maßnahmen haben sie ein bisschen geschoben.
Erst haben sie gesagt, ich habe die Patientin untersucht.
Aber wir machen ja eigentlich immer erst die Anamnese,
dann haben wir unser Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch,
und dann haben sie die Untersuchung.
Und dann ist ja immer die Frage, welche Untersuchungsschritte machen sie
und klar, das haben sie schön beschrieben,
dass sie palpieren, dass sie die Patientin abhorchen
und dann natürlich hinterher die Laborwerte und danach die Sonografie machen.
Das ist klar.
Und natürlich in dem Fall, dass es sich auf eine Gallenblasengeschichte hin orientiert,
wäre die ERCP das richtige Mittel.
Beim Ulcosventrikulid wäre, was sie genau richtig gesagt haben,
die Helicobacterdiagnose wichtig gewesen.
Und jetzt hier in diesem Fall, ja,
da kann man eigentlich überwiegend symptomatisch behandeln,
dass man die stationär aufnimmt und ihre sehr krassen Schmerzen behandelt.
Und dann muss man halt gucken,
dass man die Entzündung in der Bauchspeicheldrüse wegbekommt.
Ja, was mir aufgefallen ist,
dass sie grammatikalisch häufiger mal in der Rasereienfolge
kleine Fehler machen und zwar diese berühmte Geschichte,
dann ich habe, ja, später wir machen.
So das Verb steht an zweiter Stelle.
Das ist sehr, sehr schwierig, das konsequent durchzuziehen.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob sie noch mal Lust haben,
ihr Anamnesegespräch noch mal anzuhören.
Es waren wirklich mehrfach diese Fehler drin.
Und ich kann jetzt nicht an jeder Stelle sagen, wo das war.
Aber das ist mir schon sehr stark aufgefallen.
Was habe ich noch?
Und irgendwann einmal habe ich auch irgendwie einen Grammatikfehler
direkt korrigiert, weil es mir aufgefallen ist
und ich es so nicht stehen lassen wollte.
Aber ich habe mir das jetzt nicht extra notiert.
Es sind sprachliche Unsicherheiten durchaus noch da.
Die werden sie wahrscheinlich jetzt in der Kürze der Zeit
nicht abstellen können.
Aber versuchen sie ein bisschen, sich noch mal klar zu machen,
dass sie ein bisschen vorformulierte Sätze machen.
Insbesondere bei der Befragung, da ist es ja einfach.
Da sind Sie derjenige, der das Heft in der Hand hat,
der das Gespräch leitet.
Und da können Sie Fragen schon ein bisschen in Geiste
vorformulieren oder auch für sich zu Hause vorformulieren
und die mehr oder weniger regelmäßig in dieser Form abfragen.
Und natürlich kann man diese Vorformulierung auch dann
für den Bericht sich vorbereiten,
dass man gewisse Beispielsätze hat,
wie man etwas schildert, dass man sagt,
die familiäre Anamnese ergab, das und das.
Und ja, das ist mir aufgefallen.
Sie haben gesagt, Frau Franke ist eine 42-jährige Patientin,
1,73 und 80 Kilo.
Also 1,73 groß und 80 Kilo schwer.
Also das Gewicht beträgt 80 Kilo, sie ist 1,73 m groß.
Das sollten Sie sicherlich noch mit dazu sagen.
Das hatte ich mir hier noch unterkringelt.
Also ein bisschen besser vorformulieren,
damit Sie grammatikal richtig die Letze haben.
Und ein bisschen stringenter den Fragenkatalog durchgehen
und darauf achten, was der Patient Ihnen schon gesagt hat.
Das ist jetzt eigentlich so meine Botschaft für Sie.
Ansonsten muss ich mich entschuldigen für die schlechte Qualität
und für diese, ich weiß nicht, woran es liegt.
Ich werde noch mal mich erkundigen bei Leuten,
die sich mit Zoom-Konferenzen auskennen,
ob es irgendwie einen super Tipp gibt.
Ein bisschen besser war es aber jetzt,
nachdem ich das leiser gestellt habe, oder?
Dr. Puppel, war es da ein bisschen besser?
Ja, es wäre besser, wenn alle Mikrofonen ausgeschalten,
wäre es besser.
Aber ich glaube, die Problem ist wahrscheinlich...
Ich kann Sie jetzt fast nicht mehr verstehen.
Wahrscheinlich.
Ich glaube nicht Ihre Lautsprecher oder Mikrofonprobleme.
Wegen anderer Kollegen gibt es manchmal Probleme.
Ja, das war mein Verdacht,
dass irgendjemand seinen Mikro anhalten
und es so eine Rückkopplung gibt.
Aber wie auch immer.
Ich hoffe, dass diese Probleme
beim nächsten Mal nicht mehr auftreten.